I don't know who needs to hear this but
if you're trying to break free from diet
culture and you find yourself craving
salad or like a fresh juice or something
that you know Society considers deity
you're not relapsing you're not like
failing at intuitive eating or anti-diet
mentality if you choose a light lunch or
a smoothie for breakfast because that is
what you feel like that day diet culture
doesn't own salad or green juice or like
lemon water for goodness sakes
sometimes a super crunchy bowl of
lettuce with like lots of veggies is
what your body needs and is asking for
so if a choice is serving you it's not
diet culture let me know let me know in
the comments below if you found yourself
enjoying nourishing foods more often now
that you've let go of the rains